hi I'm Keith Danica and I'm a customer
engineer on the Apogee team today I want
to show you how Apogee can help
modernize a legacy application to enable
new digital experiences we'll look at a
demo where I'm gonna move a service from
a legacy environment to the cloud
without disruption and add a bunch of
other benefits along the way here is a
diagram that describes a problem I'm
trying to solve there's a service
running in the legacy environment and
I'd like to move it into Google cloud
I'd like to do this without disrupting
the existing applications and establish
a pattern that I can use for moving
future services I'll start by building a
facade and Apogee
I'll make well-designed rest services
that have consistent interfaces and
security and I'll map those to the
back-end services I'll map the basic
crud operations create read update and
delete to the HTTP verbs post get put
and delete I'll use a patchi's routing
features to route traffic to the right
back-end services and I'll use apogee to
manage API keys for each application and
create policies and Appaji to manage the
flow of traffic here's the goals I have
for my project first I want to move the
legacy service to the cloud with no
downtime I want to start by testing the
cloud service by routing 10% of the
traffic to the cloud make sure
everything's working the right way I
want to get visibility to which
applications are using the service today
there's a single URL we've got some logs
and things like that but I don't know
which application is sending in traffic
specifically I'll add API keys and
Appaji that'll identify individual
applications I want to add some rate
limits to protect the services we don't
want one application calling too much
we'll add call quotas based on the
partner relationships at different
partners get different quotas I want to
remove some sensitive internal data from
the partner applications I need to add
support for XML formatted data to
support some of the legacy clients if
they request XML we'll return it I want
to make it easy to onboard new
applications in the future and get ready
for the hundreds of partner applications
I know are coming and throughout all
this I want to establish a reference
architecture so that this can be the
pattern for moving future services let's
look at a demo and see how to build this
in Appaji here in Apogee I've configured
to target endpoints one for each of the
different back-end systems the legacy
system and the cloud system I also have
a URL here where it'll be listening for
traffic to come in and be routed through
Apogee
this is where I manage the request and
response flow I'll put different
policies in here to affect how the
traffic flows the first one checks for
an API key next is the spike arrest to
prevent too much traffic from coming in
and then there's a business-related
quota that's going to limit the number
of calls depending on who's calling
the next two are what we're going to use
specifically for routing
Appaji has a key value map and inside of
there I store important values I've put
a probability in there that I'm going to
use to determine how much traffic goes
to the cloud and how much goes to the
legacy system so this looks up that
value and then we're going to have some
JavaScript in here to randomly set a
flag and that flag will determine
whether we get routed to the cloud of
the legacy system let's look at how that
works in this JavaScript policy we see
there's some code referenced here so
here's our code for generating a random
number and then checking to see if it's
past the threshold and setting a flag to
true if it is so test group will be set
to true if we're in the test group down
here we have some route rules route
rules let us configure where the traffic
should be routed in Apogee you can have
multiple different backends and you can
route to different ones using some of
these rules I've got two back-end
systems in here I have the cloud system
and the legacy system if the condition
test group equals to true this rule will
be true and will be routed to the cloud
back-end that gives us a 10% chance in
this case of being routed to cloud there
are a few more goals I had for this and
we can see those on the response side
one goal was to remove sensitive data so
there's a particular field in there that
I want to take out I've got some
JavaScript in here to remove a sales
group so there's a particular field
called sales group I want to delete that
from the JSON that comes back if there's
an accept header on the request equal to
application slash XML this policy will
fire and it'll convert from JSON to XML
and return the data in XML format to
those clients who need it
I can build a custom report in Apogee to
see how much traffic is going to the
legacy environment and how much is going
to the cloud I can click through on each
metric and get more details this shows
me traffic from each of the applications
and I get an idea of who's sending the
traffic into the system one of the other
goals was to make it easy to onboard new
partners I've created a developer portal
in Apogee and this provides complete
self-service for people who want to
write applications using the API is that
I've provided they can come in here they
can read documentation about how the API
is work they could try them out and they
can sign up and get credentials that was
a quick demo about how we might use
Apogee to modernize a legacy service and
move it up to the cloud and add a bunch
of stuff along the way thanks for
watching today
[Music]